Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
So, Sophie Turner and the producers
of Game of Thrones season 5
have been talking about some crazy things happening
with the Sansa character.
So I wanted to talk about her progression
and what I think some of the changes
they made to the books mean for where
they're taking her in season 5.
Even though the TV show is changing a lot
of things about the books, I think that Dan and Dave
are taking Sansa in the same direction that
they think George R. R. Martin is taking her.
But for those that are wondering, Sansa's
character caught up to her book story
in season 4.
So whatever happens to her in season 5,
it's beyond the books.
Real quick reminder: new round of the
weekly giveaway. I'm giving away a copy
of the season 4 Blu-Ray. All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
I do have some other cool stuff to mention that I'm
going to fit at the end of the video.
Like this badass poster they released,
and the HBO streaming service.
So, all that stuff after we get through some "Dark Sansa."
Just, careful for spoilers for everything through
season 4 on the show, and all of the book stuff they've
covered on the show so far.
So let's start with the idea of "Dark Sansa."
What do I mean when I say "Dark Sansa?"
Mostly, I'm talking about the direction that
her character is headed.
Both Sophie Turner and the producers have talked,
in very general terms, that Sansa is going to have some
traumatic, eye-opening experiences in season 5.
Up to this point, you still kind of consider her
"Sweet Sansa," sweet summer-child Sansa.
She's like one of those characters that totally
bought into the idea chivalry and the fantasy of
royal society, and then over the last 4 seasons
and the first 3 books, that fantasy slowly gets burned
down in front of her.
She get's betrothed to the future king
(who winds up being a total monster),
gets brutalized by knight's like
Ser Meryn [censored] Trant here,
and then proceeds to get rescued by people
that she thinks are terrible.
Slowly along the way, her idea of reality
just gets chipped away.
Where does that leave her in season 5?
So, if you remember at the end of season 4,
Little Finger convinced Sansa to decieve Lord Royce
and the other nobles of the Vale after he
sent Lysa through the Moon Door.
They always hated Little Finger, he's an imposter in their eyes.
So, Sansa could have totally told the truth
and hung him out to dry.
I don't know if you could call telling a
bold-faced lie "courageous," but this is one of the
first times Sansa acted in her own interest,
even if it meant doing something bad.
Doing bad things for the right reasons,
or doing bad things in your own self-interest,
that is what playing the Game of Thrones is all about.
Whenever she was back in King's Landing I think
she mostly applied avoidance tactics, where she just
tried to blend in with the furniture hoping that Joffrey
would see something shiny and distract him.
Then you get to the end of season 4, and she's learning
to manipulate people, with Little Finger's help.
One of my favorite clever Sansa moments
from when this starts to happen, is when Little Finger
visits her after that meeting with Lord Royce
and she tells him, "I know what you want."
It's like her saying "I get it now, I understand what you're after."
And then the next time we see her, she's dyed her hair
black, and she's wearing this awesome looking black dress.
So when you look at her in these shots
from the season 5 trailer, you can see she's starting
to look more and more like her mother, Catelyn.
So what it seems like the producers are doing
is giving her some of the more violent aspects
of the post-Red Wedding Catelyn Stark.
I think in one of my earlier videos, I said the name
"Sansa Stoneheart," and I think that might have been
a little confusing for some people.
I wasn't saying that I think she's literally going to
go through the Lady Stoneheart storyline, I think it just
means that she's going to start murdering people
in the name of vengeance. With a lot of help from Little Finger.
Think about it this way, on the list of traumatic things
that can happen to characters, going from
"Sweet summer child," to "cold-blooded killer,"
is pretty high on the list.
And the trailer even teases this a little.
Little Finger tells Sansa,
"There's no justice in this world, not unless we make it."
And then later he says, "Avenge them," as we see
Sansa crying her eyes out.
It seems like Little Finger is trying to sell Sansa
on a complex revenge plot that involves
murdering lots of Frey's, lots of Bolton's and lots of Lannister's.
The only potential issues with this, are that
Sansa's TV show story has already caught up with her book story.
For those that haven't read the books,
Sansa's story in the books ends at the end of book 4,
whenever they have this meeting with the Lords of the Vale.
This is like the last scene that we get with her.
There was a chapter that Gerorge R. R. Martin wrote
for Winds of Winter for her character,
but because both of those books (books 4 and 5)
occur in the same time frame, I think that it was
probably just this last scene that we got with her
with Little Finger in season 4.
She's supposed to be a P.O.V. character in
Winds of Winter, but we have no idea where her story's going.
So I'm just choosing to assume that Dan and Dave are
taking Sansa in the direction that they logically think
George R. R. Martin is taking her, but you
can never predict what George R. R. Martin is going to do next.
Another really cool thing to think about is that the
false name that Sansa uses whenever they go to
the Vale to hide out, is "Stone."
So, Sansa Stoneheart / Dark Sansa,
I think it all fits together.
There are a lot of you that have asked me about
Michelle Fairley's name appearing on the IMDB page
for the season 5 finale, for season 5 episode 10.
Just because anybody with a keyboard is allowed to
edit IMDB, I wouldn't take that as being fact.
Officially, Michelle Fairley's people have said that
she has nothing to do with Game of Thrones.
I mean, you can hold out hope for her making
a guest appearance, but I don't think it's going to happen.
More cool Sansa stuff though...
Sophie Turner was just cast as Jean Grey
in the new X-Men franchise.
So she is in line to become the next Dark Phoenix.
Sophie Turner said that it was her recent work on
Game of Thrones that got the X-Men producers
interested in her.
Jean Grey, very caring sensitive person that winds up
becoming the crazy cosmic spirit of vengeance.
So I'm kind of wondering if Bryan Singer and
the X-Men people saw footage of her in season 5
and thought she'd do a really good job of pulling off
a character that can go from timid,
to really evil badass.
I mean, I don't know if they did or not, but Sophie Turner
had already filmed most of season 5
whenever she auditioned for X-Men.
So here's my big question for you guys:
do you want to see a "stabbier" version of Sansa
in season 5, or if you don't want to see her going
that direction, what do you want the producers
to do with the character?
I'm not expecting Sansa to die in season 5,
but I guess it's still a possibility.
It just seems like the producers are setting her on the
path to becoming more of a badass in her own way.
You know, just like Arya in Bravos.
Speaking of which, this poster they just released...
I mean, it looks awesome, but it makes it look like
Tyrion is going to encounter Drogon
while he's sailing to Pentos.
They might tease that, but I think this is just like
the season 4 trailer whenever we saw Drogon's shadow
over King's Landing.
It's not something that ended up happening on the show.
It was just like a "WTF?" hype moment to get everyone
crazy excited about dragons.
But I do think that we're going to see Drogon strafing
the coast for food.
Just to explain the give away for new people:
I'm doing a weekly Game of Thrones give away,
whenever we get to episode 1, I'm giving away signed
copies of A Feast for Crows and Dance with Dragons.
Signed by George R. R. Martin that is,
and they're hardbacks.
Which actually reminds me, congratulations to
this weeks give away winner, Sarah Weller!
You win a copy of the season 4 Blu-Ray.
So just be sure to message me on the back end of my
channel so that I can get your contact info.
I'm also probably going to give away some subscriptions
to the HBO streaming service.
They haven't announced an official start date yet,
but they're probably going to open in up for
subscriptions at the beginning of April
The season 5 premier is April 12th, so what they'll
probably do is they'll open it up for subscriptions
within about 2 weeks of that.
They haven't said how much it's going to cost,
but most of the best estimates that I've seen so far
are $15 U.S. dollars.
And they haven't announced whether or not it's going
to be available internationally, but worst case scenario,
you access it just like you access HBO GO with a proxy service.
So even if you're outside of the U.S., you should still
be able to pay money and legit watch Game of Thrones,
like, you won't have to pirate it.
I'm totally down with whatever ways you guys use to
watch the show, but I do ask that you guys not paste
pirate-streaming links in the comments.
Right now we're within the 6 week window of
season 5 starting, so I hope you're all getting crazy excited.
Please leave me all of your requests for bonus videos,
there's still plenty of time to do all kinds of fun stuff
between now and then.
I think my next video is probably going to be
a Danerys video, so be sure to subscribe to get that,
I'll post that next week.
While you guys wait for that to drop, you can click here
for my Jon Snow video and you can click her for my
list of unexpected deaths that I think might be happening.
Thank you so much for watching!
So let's all high-five, I'll see you guys tonight!